table en solde et peut-être bientôt en
friche le marché foncier agricole est en
crise
mesdames messieurs bonsoir c'est un
véritable exploit que vient d'accomplir
le champion cycliste néerlandais iops
auto melk à 39 ans et alors qu'il
dispute sa 16e saison professionnelle
il a remporté aujourd'hui son premier
titre de champion du monde sur route en
italie il a surpris tout le monde car le
grand favori c'était bernard hinault
mais le breton n'a pas réussi à rééditer
l'exploit réalisé hier par jeannie longo
michel dhrey 14h20 bernard hinault
quitte le peloton le favori de ce
championnat du monde n'est pas au mieux
je suis saturé de vélodi rayno après son
abandon
c'est l'une des principales victimes de
cette longue course par élimination
van der ardennes mathis cuyper ont subi
le même sort
devant leur public sur le circuit jeeha
verra del monte l'eau les italiens
contrôler la course
le rythme est extrêmement rapide on
roule à près de 42 km de moyenne horaire
il ne faut surtout pas oublier de se
ravitailler un coup de fringale est si
vite arrivé surtout dans les derniers
kilomètres stéphane roche qui reste sur
un très beau tour de france va bien
tenté de s'échapper
l'irlandais profite d'une petite
difficulté pour prendre quelques
longueurs
mais derrière un groupe de 12 coureurs
même la chasse et parmi eux un certain
greg lemon qui s'y prend à deux fois
pour contre attaquer lemon est suivi de
très près par diop hotmail stéphane
roche n'insiste plus adieu le titre
mondial derniers kilomètres l'italien
argentine lemon criquelion marc madiot
millar fernandez ne conjugue pas bien
leurs efforts un homme leur a faussé
compagnie aux bretons mail qu'il a pris
20 50 100 m l'arrivée est au bout de la
ligne droite trop tard messieurs un
jeune homme de 39 ans aura champion du
monde vainqueur du tour de france en
1981 cet e mail dispute là sa dernière
saison
ce titre mondial vient récompenser un
champion reconnu et apprécié deuxième
lemon troisième argentine quatrième
madiot
les autres nouvelles de sport encore une
médaille d'or encore une médaille pour
la france aux championnats du monde
d'aviron disputée en belgique que
thierry renault et luc crispons ont donc
remporté la médaille d'or de l'épreuve
deux de couple poids léger tennis aux
internationaux des états-unis à flushing
meadow les français le comte et noah
viennent de se qualifier aisément pour
les huitièmes de finale n'a abattu
gerulaitis en trois sets
enfin en sport automobile le champion du
monde d'endurance l'allemand de l'ouest
stefan bellof s'est tué cet après midi
au cours des 1000 km de spa en belgique
en afrique du sud
les émeutes qui se poursuivent sans
relâche depuis un an on fait aujourd'hui
deux victimes blanche de civils l'un
poignardé l'autre brûlées vives dans sa
voiture par des noirs qui venait
d'assister à l'enterrement de 19 des
leurs mais mona à fidji hintermann 50000
personnes aux funérailles de 19 noirs ou
métis tués par l'armée où la police lors
des dernières émeutes parmi les
cercueils celui de l'enfant de sept mois
à ceux fixés par une grenade lacrymogène
cinquante mille manifestants qui crient
amanda favier le pouvoir quiconque elle
soupçonnait d'être du côté de ce pouvoir
est une cible
cet homme accusé d'être un indicateur a
échappé de justesse à la foule ne voilà
emprisonné de vos pneus promis être
lapidée et brûlé vif
il échappera de justesse grâce au mas
secourable de religieux témoin de la
scène
l'état d'urgence décrété dans trente six
districts devait empêcher l'extension de
l'agitation commencé il ya un an tout
l'arsenal répressif mis en place à cet
effet se montrer efficace émeutes
répression mort c'est devenu quotidien
le gouvernement sud-africain rejette le
concept da par tag si cela signifie la
justice discrimination raciale est
atteinte à la dignité de l'homme
c'est un communiqué du ministère sud
africain des affaires étrangères lue à
la radio aujourd'hui
ce texte a été rédigé après les
entretiens des trois ministres européens
des affaires étrangères avec les
autorités de pretoria
en écho
le pasteur besac l'une des grandes
figures antiapartheid arrêté cette
semaine a déclaré au journal allemand
der spiegel
l'afrique du sud volera un jour en
éclats sous les pieds des blancs et ils
n'auront toujours pas compris et
parallèlement la situation économique de
l'afrique du sud s'aggrave très
sérieusement puisque ce soir le
gouvernement de pretoria vient
d'annoncer qu'il suspendait pour quatre
mois le paiement de sa dette extérieure
alors en clair mais mona ça peut vouloir
dire que les partenaires occidentaux
finances hybrides issus de lâche ce pays
c'est la première fois que l'afrique du
sud ait lâché par ses partenaires
occidentaux
on peut dire que c'est un coup très dur
pour que sa crédibilité
cette semaine le gouverneur de la banque
centrale sud africaine est allé en
grande bretagne en allemagne fédérale
aux états unis est nulle part il n'a
obtenu le renouvellement des crédits
nécessaires au paiement de la dette sud
africaine c'est une aide qui n'est pas
très énorme 18 milliards dé dollars
c'est une dette importante mais vu les
ressources des ressources stratégiques
leur source industrielle on peut pas
dire qu'elle soit démesurée elle est
devenue simplement plus fragiles parce
que les deux tiers sont à court terme
maintenant le gouverneur avait même
proposé de gager tout le stock d'or sud
africain c'est le plus important du
monde pour obtenir l'équivalent de
crédit au delà à rien il n'a rien obtenu
n'a pas convaincu
alors si l'afrique du sud a perdu la
confiance de ses partenaires financiers
ce n'est pas du tout pour une question
morale les milieux financiers sont tout
à fait à morrow et entendu on sait
simplement c'est parce que ces milieux
financiers trouve que l'afrique du sud
n'est plus un pays sûr ce n'est plus si
des pays à risque à cause de toutes ces
manifestations que l'on connaît depuis
un an
certains experts commencent à comparer
aujourd'hui la situation en afrique du
sud c'est ce qui s'est passé dans les
rangs du chalet dernières années et ils
se disent que toutes les réformes qui
seront proposés finalement seront
interprétées comme des concessions d'eau
qu'ils accordent ils sont prudents et
ils ont peur en pologne des dizaines de
milliers de partisans de solidarité ont
célébré publiquement dans plusieurs
villes du pays le 5e anniversaire des
accords de danse qu'aujourd'hui et puis
le pape jean paul 2 qui recevait à
castel gandolfo un groupe de pèlerins
polonais a lancé un appel pour que les
accords doute 80 soit respectée en
pologne
en france le bilan définitif de la
catastrophe ferroviaire d'argenton sur
creuse et finalement de 42 morts 36
blessés graves dont 11 dans un état
critique
toute la journée les familles des
victimes ont défilé aujourd'hui dans
cette chapelle ardente où l'on a
rassemblé leurs cercueils
le responsable de l'accident par
ailleurs le conducteur du train a été
inculpé ce matin pour homicide et
blessures involontaires mais le
procureur l'a laissé en liberté sous
contrôle judiciaire
en revanche l'agriculteur qui avait
provoqué l'accident routier d'artenay
dans le loiret vendredi en allumant un
feu en bordure de la route est en prison
lui il a été inculpé également ce matin
l'accident avait fait je vous le
rappelle huit morts et 10 blessés
un sénateur du parti radical jacques
tout un est mort subitement cet après
midi victime d'un malaise alors qu'il
participait à l'université d'été des
radicaux à grasse jacques tout un élu
des yvelines avait succédé à madame
brigitte de gros elle même décédée il ya
quelques mois ne fait plus le disent sur
votre cadran de téléphone depuis
aujourd'hui le service du pcv ne
fonctionne plus les ptt explique que il
leur coûtait trop cher et que par
ailleurs cinq nouveaux services peuvent
maintenant remplacer le pc vd service
qui s'adresse essentiellement aux
entreprises car elles étaient les
principales consommatrices de pcv 70 %
des appels à peu près reste bien sûr les
30 autres pourcents c'est à dire vous et
moi
alors comment faire maintenant pour
appeler quand on n'a pas un sou en poche
ah non j'ai re vacanciers délesté de vos
portefeuilles jeunes les poches
concrètement vive attention le pcv ne
répond plus abréviation du mot
percevoir il existait depuis 1935 un
numéro le disent et c'était votre
correspondant qui paient la peine finie
la demoiselle du téléphone à la place le
rappel dans les cabines mais voilà il
faut de l'argent pour le premier appel
alors revenons à la case départ
terminé le temps où le pcv et est le
dernier recours
le sos dipômés s'il est dans un cas de
détresse normalement l'appel à la police
au samu ou aux pompiers devraient
suffire pour les autres cas qui
pourraient se présenter
eh bien nous avons donné instruction à
nos agents de se comporter comme des
agents du service public ils peuvent ils
pourront continuer à titre tout à fait
transitoire est exceptionnel à acheminer
certains appellent un service supprimer
un autre ne remplace c'est le premier
argument les ptt
le deuxième argument décourager le
vandaliser 210 1000 cabines dévalisé
l'an dernier 400 millions de perte sèche
alors la solution dans de l'huile plus
d'argent du tou tes les cartes cartes
vacances
l'ère de la monétique a commencé mais
commençait seulement car il est encore
difficile de les utiliser ces fameuses
cartes peu de points de vente seulement
7000 cabines équipées alors la question
se pose
fallait il supprimer le pcv dès
maintenant ou attendre qu'ils tombent de
lui-même en désuétude puisque les appels
ont chuté de 40% depuis le début de
l'année ne voulons pas être mise en
carte ne voulons pas avoir l'obligation
mais nous voulons avoir la possibilité
d'utiliser un ordinateur un écran
minitel une carte
il faut laisser à l'utilisateur le choix
entre ses services à haute technicité et
un service un présence humaine
nous voulons je veux pouvoir appeler une
opératrice et lui demander de l'aide à
résoudre mon problème notamment pour
appeler quelqu'un si je me retrouve sans
argent
alors nouvelle version du combat des
anciens et des modernes le pc ray
technologie contre demoiselles du
téléphone grandes manoeuvres financières
dans le secteur de l'industrie nucléaire
française framatome le numéro deux
mondial des constructeurs de chaudières
nucléaires passe en grande partie sous
le contrôle de l'état par
l'intermédiaire du groupe nationalisé
cge framatome devait trouver de nouveaux
actionnaires à cause de la faillite du
groupe privé creusot-loire été dernier
faisons loire détenait 50% du capital
marie carrière après le dépôt de bilan
de creusot loire sa filiale framatome
7600 salarié n'avait plus qu'un seul
actionnaire
le commissariat à l'énergie atomique les
pouvoirs publics décidée à reconstituer
le capital de framatome exclut tout
d'abord qu'un des nouveaux candidats
puissent détenir à lui seul plus de 50%
deuxièmement il opte pour une hiérarchie
parmi les prétendants en lice
désormais le capital sera ainsi réparti
le groupe nationalisé cge devient le
leader industriel avec 40%
le commissariat à l'énergie atomique ne
vient qu'au second rang avec 35 % et se
voit donc attribuer la minorité de
blocage
dumez société de bâtiment et travaux
publics seuls actionnaires privés
obtient 12% et df 10 % et 3 % seront
proposées au personnel de framatome la
présence de la société bouygues n'a pas
été retenu fram atone se retrouve donc
avec un actionnariat diversifié mais où
le secteur public occupe une place
désormais dominante
une solution qui satisfait les syndicats
mais si les commandes vont pouvoir
reprendre
reste le problème du ralentissement du
programme nucléaire en france les
producteurs ils ne dépendent pas des
industriels dépendent des consommateurs
et ils ne changeront pas mais ce que ça
va permettre une meilleure coopération
de l'ensemble des acteurs français les
industriels et des f
serra et par conséquent de meilleures
chances de gagner sur les marchés
d'exportation
je vous rappeler que sur ce match et
l'exportation nous sommes très bien
passé pas seulement sur le problème des
centrales mais sur des marchés très gros
qui sont ce les combustibles qu'on met
des centrales nucléaires sur les
services nucléaires
et là dessus nous sommes de très gros
exportateurs par exemple nous sommes le
premier exportateur français au japon
et tout ça qu on fera travailler
ensemble mieux ça vaudra
reste à savoir si ce montage permettra
d'assurer l'avenir de framatome et en
1989 n'aura plus à construire qu'une
seule tranche nucléaire par an contre 4
actuellement une partie des percussive
abl en france risquent bientôt de se
transformer en jachère les sociétés
d'aménagement foncier hier les affaires
viennent de publier ce propos un rapport
inquiétant
on y voit que depuis quelques années le
prix de la terre a baissé de moitié dans
certaines régions comme celle où l'on
pratique l'élevage clos guinot et
dominique duchateau ont enquêté dans le
département de l'orne la vallée de la
sarthe fait partie des régions les plus
menacés par la désertification sa 18
hectares de prairies sont en vente
depuis près de deux ans aucun acheteur
ne s'est proposé il ya quelques années
encore on se les arrachaient mais
aujourd'hui les éleveurs de l'ouest
confrontés aux problèmes de
surproduction et à la dégradation de
leurs revenus ne cherche plus à agrandir
leur exploitation conséquence la terre a
perdu la moitié de sa valeur
mais même à ce prix elle ne trouve pas
preneur et la boue on arriverait encore
à les vendre aux alentours de entre 18
et 20 mille francs en fin de semaine de
16 à 20 mille francs suivant la
catégorie mais ce sont les prairies
qu'on n'arrive pas à vendre
même aux environs de 10 mille francs
alors qu'il ya quelques années ça valait
beaucoup plus cher oui c'était au moins
25 de l'autre côté de cette de la
nationale il ya eu des terres bondi à 4
59 ans ha c'était des terres recherché
pour la production de boeuf traditionnel
mais comment on sait tous aujourd'hui le
marasme de du marché de la viande bovine
plus personne intéressée par ces termes
ces terres dont personne ne veut se sont
essentiellement les prairies qui ont
fait de l'ouest une grande région
d'élevage
seulement aujourd'hui ce secteur est en
crise la viande se vend mal et la
production laitière limité par les
quotas je pense que les quotas laitiers
dans une rue
comme la nôtre on fait énormément de mal
dans le sens que désherbage qui serait
destinée ou les actuellement ils ne
peuvent plus être pris parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'autres productions qui permettent
de dégager un revenu dans l'immédiat
avec ses terres alors alors je pense que
si on arrive à son n'arrive pas à mettre
sur pied un système d'incitations pour
des jeunes d'autres régions à venir dans
la région
malheureusement la plupart de ces terres
resteront l'abandon des terres à
l'abandon il risque d'y en avoir de plus
en plus car la france rurale vieilli six
agriculteurs sur dix n'ont pas de
successeur on estime que d'ici à 1990 4
millions d'hectares vont se transformer
en friche soit plus de 10 % de la
surface agricole les régions d'élevage
seront les plus touchés la terre a cessé
d'être une valeur sûre pour les
investisseurs extérieurs c'est même
devenu un déplacement les moins
rentables tandis que beaucoup de jeunes
hésitent à s'endetter pour s'installer
une désaffection qui ne sera pas sans
influence sur le paysage rural de demain
nous retrouverons sans doute dès la
semaine prochaine les traditionnels
petites phrases politiques du dimanche
soir pour le moment la véritable rentrée
n'est pas encore fait
même si pierre mauroy l'ancien premier
ministre l'a quelque peu pressés dès ce
matin à lille mais c'était un exercice
un peu particulier et périlleux aussi il
était invité sur france inter de
l'oreille en coin qui se veut une
émission plus humoristique que politique
mais la frontière est parfois floue
entre les deux
fernand tavarès lorsque l'humour et la
politique sont à la fiche le public à
coup au palais des congrès de ville ce
matin deux mille personnes ont voulu
manquer à aucun prix la rentrée de
pierre mauroy face aux chansonniers de
l'oreille en coin lille qui inaugure
également sa grande braderie annuelle
alors jacques mailhot propose qui paraît
que durant cette braderie on peut se
débarrasser de tous alors j'ai
je suis né avec un programme commun dans
ma mallette à ce que vous pensez vous
manivelle se prend c'est plus
d'actualité et alors remettre de ces
questions c'est pas la peine de le céder
parce que je connais à peu près marqueur
et goûter on peut s'installer ce soir
avec le programme commun
il ya des amateurs de rap voulait
vendriez combien moment annoncent eux
c'est gratuit et pour qu'ils laissent
faire questions politico littéraire de
la semaine cette fois faut-il mettre les
français en espadrilles
je sais pas pourquoi monsieur giscard
d'estaing choisi les espadrilles
pourquoi la france en espadrilles on
nous ramène à un bond de chocques
pourquoi ça et je ne comprends pas je
crois que c'est une c'est un contre sens
de ma génération ont parlé des ponts
qu'on était bien dans ses pompes
on est en dehors de ses pompes bon
tandis que moins de temps j'entends la
jeunesse ils disent était bien dans ses
baskets tout et pas dans tes baskets
espadrilles connaissent pas vous parler
de basket maintenant je ne vais pas vous
vous pensez qu'il vaut mieux
aller aux élections de 86 avec des
godillots premier avec des baskets
beaucoup plus sérieux et peut-être même
inquiétant cette dernière nouvelle qui
m'arrive à l'instinct propos du proche
orient la marine israélienne vient
d'annoncer qu'elle avait intercepté ce
soir un bateau de plaisance à bord
duquel se trouvaient 10 toujours les
israéliens un commando palestinien du
fatah c'est à dire la principale
composante de l'olp et le bateau ajoute
le communiqué d'israël transportait
également deux occidentaux on n'en dit
pas davantage on ne dit pas non plus en
quel lieu précis a été intercepté ce
bateau les isréliens dis simplement que
l'opération a eu lieu en méditerranée on
n'en sait pas davantage pour le moment
succès total cette fois pour l'équipage
de la navette américaine discovery après
deux jours de travail acharné les
mécanos de l'espace ont pu réparer tout
effet le satellite qu'ils avaient
récupéré hier daniel durand dette
c'est une véritable prouesse technique
mais aussi physique on le voit quand
accompli james van noten et bill fisher
une réparation très minutieuse qui aura
duré plus de 12 heures passées dans le
vide spatial avec en alternance toutes
les 45 minutes une période de jours
suivie de la nuit sidérale une
réparation qui présentait des risques
considérables pour la première fois en
effet il leur fallait bricoler un
satellite rempli de combustible
représentant la charge de cinq tonnes de
tnt
après avoir fixé hier une dérivation sur
le boîtier électrique du satellite qui
avaient été défaillants en avril dernier
il aurait 7 aujourd'hui à le protéger
des terribles variations de température
du vide spatial
une fois terminée c'est opération très
délicate répétée des dizaines de fois
dans la piscine d'entraînement des
astronautes de houston ron open perché à
l'extrémité du bras robot du vaisseau a
ensuite fait tourner lentement le
satellite sur lui même avant de le
catapulter dans l'espace pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'astronautique à la force du poignet
succès total pour la nasa mais aussi
excellente répétition pour les
astronautes en vue du travail qui dans
sept ans d antan là-haut dans l'aspect
stations américaines ont fleuri de la
tempête qui menace depuis 48 heures n'a
pas encore vraiment aborder les côtes et
pourtant elle a déjà causé des dégâts
importants
près d'un million de personnes près d'un
million d'américains ont déjà fui vers
le nord abandonnant leurs habitations
eric pirro les petits bungalows de la
côte de floride ont été balayés comme
des châteaux de cartes
la mère qui a franchi les digues et les
dunes a envahi les terres les bateaux
sont ballottés par les vagues qui
dépassent parfois les 5 mètres
le vent qui souffle à plus de 130 km
heure a arraché des centaines de
kilomètres de lignes électriques et
téléphoniques
les dégâts sont considérables il
pourrait dépasser selon certains
spécialistes le chiffre d'un milliard de
dollars
et pourtant l'ouragan elena n'a pas
encore frappé
ils continuent de se déplacer toujours
insaisissable au large des côtes
tous ces dommages ont été causés en fait
par les tornades qui le précède
c'est un acte qui il est vrai ne sont
pas exceptionnelles dans cette région
n'ont fait pour le moment qu'un seul
mort tué par un arbre arraché du sol
c'est peut-être parce que la plupart des
habitants de la région
plus d'un million de personnes se sont
réfugiées à l'intérieur des terres elles
sont encore logés dans les écoles les
églises les centres d'accueil de la
croix-rouge et les hôtels tout le monde
attend de pouvoir rentrer mais elena
menacent toujours
elle peut sur e bay sur la côte à tout
moment en moins d'une heure
les résultats du tiercé qui aujourd'hui
se disputer à longchamp il fallait jouer
20 25 et 4 dans l'ordre les rapports
57000 97 francs dans un ordre différent
7663 francs 50 centimes pour 5 francs le
temps demain il va se dégrader sur le
nord-ouest du pays avec des nuages et de
la pluie d'abord sur la bretagne puis
sur la normandie le bassin parisien et
la champagne ailleurs la journée sera
belle malgré quelques nuages sur le jura
et sur la savoie
les températures baisseront de 2 degrés
à peu près sur le nord-ouest des partout
ailleurs elles resteront semblable à
celle d'aujourd'hui demain soir vous
avez rendez vous avec geneviève
guicheney à 22h tout rond dans un
instant au cinéma de minuit le roman
d'un tricheur 2 et avec sacha guitry
excellent de fin de soirée avant de vous
quitter je vous rappelle les principales
nouvelles de la journée bonsoir
cyclisme le iop hotmail que devient
champion du monde sur route à 39 ans
belle fin de carrière afrique du sud les
ennuis financiers se confirme et
pretoria suisse quand le remboursement
de ces dettes ne fait plus le disent sur
le cadre du téléphone le pcv en france
ne répond plus
normalement
non